chez le maire jean-michel vers vous le
dit jean michel maire est amoureux il a
eu un petit croche pied des tours ride
est lourd c'est très bien pour qui il a
eu un petit croche
il était avec elle il ya un instant on
reloge 1
on ne dit pas de qui il s'agit on ne le
dira jamais mais pas pour la vie nous
cache qu'il a une brébeuf en fait
comment tu as une meuf en ce moment il
paraît qu'il était célibataire
allez je vous dit pas toute la vérité ou
non mais oui je ne veux commencer vous
la connaissez les je connais votre 9
noyer je exact quoi ah oui oui bah je
vois votre sourire que commença à
comprendre quoi s'est il a repris à oui
j'ai repris un genre tombé dedans non a
les deux pieds en avant
mais quand on n'y comprend rien
il est vrai qu'une mode à deux en oiseau
clair vous avez repris avec elle jérôme
si génial alors celles quittant des
salles de la loge
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'amie d'une amie en amitié regard
déterminé on est ami martin et moi on a
mis très chaleureux et ses amis comme
vous êtes chaleureusement que jean
michel aulas on va pas se mentir on voit
qu'aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui se passe votre caméra que
thomas c'est une caméra qui est tombée
c'est pas mal c'est pas nous qui payons
et non mais je me tais car prick tama
fouet
je vais pas trop le dire mais bon
comment tu vas voulu me le dire bah je
sais pas je suis très discret moi je
comprends rien alors et l'autre dans la
loge alors elle lui nous l'oural à
l'école malgré la notion d'école et les
connais pas gentil bord